Every now and then,
a monster comes around
that's a real "head-scratcher."
Siren Head's exaggerated
humanoid shape
is scary, sure,
but it's the inexplicable
horn-shaped speakers
emanating constant
blaring noise
that invokes
an unusual brand of terror
as it looms over landscapes.
While you could technically
call this monster "humanoid,"
there's no doubt it's also
an Eldridge being--
a weird, eerie,
malevolent force.
Known for its impressive
hunting skills,
despite its lack of eyes,
the origins of its anatomy
remain largely a mystery--
perfect fodder
for digital folklore.
Siren Head exists
in illusory realism,
which makes its appearance
in digitally altered images
in videos
that much more convincing.
And we are invited
to participate in the expansion
and spread of its lore
through digital interactions.
Since its digital creation
in 2018,
online gaming communities,
YouTube creators,
artists and TikTokers
have embraced Siren Head,
building creepy worlds
for it to inhabit.
So what does Siren Head's
growing social media presence
tell us about folklore
in the digital age?
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka,
and this is "Monstrum."
On August 19, 2018,
at 11:09 am,
a user Tweeted a grainy photo
of a strange being
accompanied by a short
eye-witness account.
According
to this first narrative,
while sightseeing graveyards,
as one does,
a woman saw it motionless.
Initially,
she thought the thing--
as big as an old
macabre telephone pole--
was an art installation...
that is,
before it blared to life
with sound buzzing out,
"Nine, eighteen, one,
child, seventeen,
remove, vile."
Then it started
walking towards her.
That's it--that's where
her story ends
and the legend
of Siren Head begins.
So, how is a modern monster
even born?
It's rare I get to talk
to an actual monster creator.
After all, most of the creatures
covered here on "Monstrum"
go so far back
into human history,
a lot of the original content
was made hundreds
or thousands of years ago.
So, outside of a séance,
I have little chance
of getting any face time
with the earliest storytellers.
But not this time.
I got the chance to talk to
Siren Head's original creator,
horror artist
Trevor Henderson.
So, Siren Head is probably
my most popular character.
He really blew up
on YouTube
and all kinds
of social media sites
and really caught on
with a lot of people.
I was really obsessed
with the concept
of number stations
at the time.
Number stations are
these sort of anomalous,
very ominous,
scary broadcasts
that are still happening
today on the radio waves,
that are frequently just,
like, chanting numbers
and random words
and nursery-rhyme
kind of jingles.
The leading theory on them
is that they are
abandoned spy broadcasts
from the world wars.
But nobody really knows
for sure exactly what they are,
and I thought that was
a really mysterious concept,
and, you know, I thought
that would be really cool
as a basis for a monster.
(Dr. Zarka)
Roughly 40 feet tall,
Siren Head gains
its distinctive name
from its odd head--
two metal horn-style speakers.
These speakers
emit constant noise--
strange music,
snippets of human conversation,
electrical sounds,
random numbers, and words;
even white noise
while it sleeps.
Its body is an elongated,
long-limbed humanoid skeleton
covered in mummified skin,
with the occasional electrical
wire appearing under the flesh.
While it has no eyes,
it's an incredibly
effective predator.
And it kind of wanders through
the Pacific Northwest woods.
It can mimic people
and other sounds
and animals
to lure in its victims,
which it disposes of.
(Dr. Zarka)
The extremely long arms
and ability to stand
perfectly motionless for days
allow it to blend
into even forests,
despite its appearance
as a streetlight
or a telephone pole.
It often stalks rural towns,
dusty roads,
and seemingly
abandoned landscapes.
Like so many monsters
before it,
Siren Head's notoriety
grew as its presence
in popular culture increased,
and video games offered
a ready-made stage.
In 2018, a short game
produced by Modus Interactive,
called "Siren Head,"
featured the creature.
You play as a forest ranger
who has to evade Siren Head
while searching
for a lost hiker.
Then, in 2019,
gamers playing the "Fallout 4"
mod Whispering Hills
could see and hear the creature
in a fog-covered world
broadcasting static,
claxon alarms,
and emergency message warnings.
Videos of startled gamers
stumbling upon
the in-game creature
can be found
all over the Internet.
Siren Head reached a new level
in 2020 thanks to TikTok.
On April 30, digital artist
Alex Howard
posted a video of Siren Head
over a soundtrack
of blaring police sirens
and muted gunfire--
the palm-tree-lined
city location
taking the rural monster
into an urban space.
The post got 23 million views
and 3.3 million likes
in a week.
And it really contributed
to Siren Head becoming,
like, this extremely strange
viral phenomenon out of nowhere,
that I could
never have predicted,
and I never would have
predicted.
It's still very baffling to me
even now.
If you've ever been on TikTok,
you'll already know that
repetition and imitation
are foundational.
What does that mean
for horror?
There's an active interest in
not just sharing spooky videos
but contributing to them
in some way,
making it easy to shape an
emerging monster's development.
Think of it
as crowd-sourced horror.
In a way, many
of the original monster videos
found on TikTok
could also be considered
an emerging subgenre
of folk horror.
While Siren Head
is decidedly modern,
its old-fashioned speakers
and original rural,
remote hunting-ground spaces
help us conceptualize
the monster as legendary
or at least,
a relic of the past.
And in a very meta way,
TikTok might also be
the isolating space
where the storytelling
that contributes to Siren Head
occurs in a futuristic
folkloresque.
The very idea that folklore
can even be transmitted
and performed in digital spaces
is a new one.
Sure, the volume of people
editing photographs,
re-treating scary stories,
or posting creative
TikTok horror shorts
may be massive in scale,
but behind almost every post
is a real person
whose contribution
to the genre
shapes these modern monsters.
As new manifestations
are crafted and distributed,
people add their own twists,
based on their own fears
and anxieties,
contributing
to digital folk culture.
How it's kind of been
adopted by
a lot of YouTubers
and people online for children.
I mean, I never designed
Siren Head for kids.
It's really cool that it's
resonated with so many kids,
but, you know,
I hope I'm not giving anyone
sleepless nights or whatnot.
(Dr. Zarka)
The question, of course, is:
What is Siren Head
a symbol of?
What fears or anxieties
about this moment in time
does it represent?
I just wanted to heighten
how strange
I could make the creature,
and make it feel very
not-of-this-world--
like having human features,
such just teeth or arms
on something that's clearly
maybe not 100% organic,
and incorporating technology
or broken malfunctioning bits
of machinery into it.
It all added--it was all
to add up and make it
as disconcerting and scary,
I guess, as possible.
(Dr. Zarka)
I find the telephone pole
or streetlight comparisons
interesting.
Unlike other monsters
throughout history,
or even more modern ones
like Slender Man,
Siren Head is inherently linked
to our use of technology,
as indicated by
its preferred disguises
as a telephone pole
or streetlight,
not to mention
its speaker head.
(Henderson)
A lot of people draw parallels
between Siren Head
and Slender Man.
I think Slender Man's
a great monster.
So any comparisons,
you know,
I think that's
a great compliment.
(Dr. Zarka)
Fear of technology
is a common trope,
but the old-timey look
of Siren Head
suggests an uneasy nostalgia.
We look back into the past
with new eyes,
or our phone cameras,
and find new horrors
along the way.
I also can't help
thinking of Siren Head
as a representative
boundary creature
akin to the original concept
of the troll,
which is a label
for any antisocial creature
that occupies a space outside
of so-called civilization
and poses a threat
to the living things
within the community.
Siren Head occupies spaces
that are becoming increasingly
less inhabited by humans--
environments heavily impacted
by economic factors
and urban encroachment.
Siren Head is the result
of imagination
and artistic interpretations
of fear.
Folklore's evolution
in popular culture
makes new monsters
like this one stand out
alongside more traditional,
rigid structures
or sequential stories.
Digital folklore is
more like an amalgamation
of superstitions
and preternatural possibilities
borrowed from a variety
of traditions.
Folklore changes
through time and space,
picking up variations
in the way it is told
and retold and by whom,
which can be a really fruitful
mode for creative exploration.
And I think social media
is definitely the modern-day--
a huge facet, sorry,
in the modern-day folklore,
and Creepypasta is, like,
kind of the biggest example
of that, I guess.
I think we miss
that communal storytelling
that we used to have
a lot more
before social media--
you know, like telling stories
around the campfire, maybe.
And, you know, it's the closest
approximation of that
is being able to throw stories
and monsters
back and forth online,
on Twitter or Instagram.
Like the creature's reported
ability to blend easily
into its environment,
the adaptability of modern
Internet monster lore
is significant.
Still, there is a self-awareness
to Siren Head.
No one is sincerely arguing
that this monster exists
in the real world.
Instead, it serves
as self-conscious fiction
that explores the boundaries
of art, technology, and fear.
I'm totally honored.
And the idea that kids
could be inspired
by my monsters
and my art
to do their own monsters,
which will inevitably be
way cooler and better
eventually,
it's totally--
it's a total honor.
And I'm just so happy that
Siren Head could be that
for a whole lot
of different kids.
It's super cool.
(speaker)
Ready?
I'm ready. That slimy
swamp ghost himself...
Let's do it again.
Oh, okay, yeah.
But it's an illusion.
[laughs]